[Music]
just the halls for us because
this personality that comes a
person is very very very dear and
left us by decided for
decades and we are here today
to welcome with joy
and gladness
because c  is a personality
that is needed for
true reconciliation and the advancement of the country
[Music]
designer
TV he is like a man who has been
deprived for almost ten years of
returning home and who finds the
freedom to finally be able to return to
his country and find his family so he
is in a happy state of mind
enthusiastic about the idea of being able to retur
home and he hopes in any case
e wants to play his part for the could
try to reconcile the  Ivor
it seems necessary to me
[Music]
biadillah difficult to forgive and we
live the
situation indeed nothing we are there and we are
victims of this situation of which we
our care it is well found  find a
solution so that we can forgive or
else it's not always a given
that we can't find the solution we ca
n't forgive
[Music]